are you gonna answer that
it's not mine
sorry who is this
do I have your attention
that I do something to you you sound so
guilty what do you want drive to this
location
honey Something's Happened there's a man
who's put a bomb in the car
under our seats there are pressure
triggers
[Music]
can't get up the car will explode
we're here listen very carefully or I
kill you open the glove box
shoot him
why are you doing this
what have I ever done to you this life
or yours Matt I'm your best friend
you think I'm the bomber
well I guess you've had a tough day
I know that you've lost a lot of money
for your clients who invest it in your
fund
a lot of people are worried about you
you've got everybody's attention mad
you're still out there if you can't find
them I will I'm in control no you're not
you hurt my darling son of a I
will kill you
What's it gonna be
Drive